[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Dalton is
with us in Indianapolis to start this
hour hi Dalton welcome to the Ramsey
show Hello thank you for having me sure
what's
up so about a year ago um soon after I
got my first job I invested into an IU
ilul due to talking to my parents
financial advisor and since after having
kind of see some of your work I saw I
one of the videos you guys talking about
it and I kind of looked into it myself I
kind of decided I would like to get out
of this however the problem is is
there's a surrender charge so I have
about um I've been invested since last
November and I have about like $1,500
invested but if I were to try I can't
transfer it into anything else if I try
to leave it I'd be left with
$400 and the uh surrender charge isn't
go away until like another 10 years and
I'd have to keep investing so I'm not
sure what to do about this
well it sounds like you've lost $1,100
to
me yeah and um yeah make note that this
guy screwed
you putting you into this product I mean
put you in a product that the only way
you avoid surrender charges is 10
years MH oh man how old are you uh 20
good Lord man I'm sorry this this one
under stupid tax and we've all paid our
version of it but I hate that you have
to deal with this and lose that 1100 the
only the only other option is continue
to pay them money and lose even
more yeah what are you paying into this
thing um it's 150 a month what do you
make um 22,000 a year my gosh God what
do you do for a living
Dalton I'm a diesel technician okay all
right
well
um as painful as it is and I'm I'm
hurting with you right now and I'm kind
of angry at this character for putting
you in this thing um as painful as it is
I I would stop now and let me just tell
you here's an interesting story I was
22 and a guy that was in the in a
fraternity that my wife had been the
little sister to the fraternity came to
our house with Northwestern Mutual sold
me a whole life policy and I've got a
finance degree I should know better um
and oddly enough Dalton that was a long
time ago but it was 150 a month and when
I discovered like you have about a year
in that I had to stop that i' had been
screwed then I cancelled it and you know
how much of my cash value I got zero I
lost about the same amount you're going
to lose and I was 22 years old but but
that doesn't mean that I would you know
staying in it would have just been
worse yeah you're going to pay 1,800
this year just paying into that thing
the bad news for Northwestern Mutual in
my case is is that I've gotten to tell
this story now for 40 years about how
they screwed me they've lost a lot of
customers thanks to you you know it's
cost them a lot more than the little bit
of money they got out of me and I've
gotten almost as much satisfaction as
the money they got out of me so it was
worth it yeah but you're not going to
get that opportunity I doubt as a diesel
mechanic you might you might tell some
other diesel mechanics not to do
business with this particular guy but
yeah I'm sorry Dalton but the actual
actual proper correct thing to do is
just if you have a hole in your pocket
sew up the hole don't keep putting money
in it yep you that's kind of what I
figured but um you know I just want to
make sure there was no other options but
you know and don't be mad at your mom
and dad they don't know any better the
financial advisor should know better but
a financial advisor that sells universal
life is is not a financial adviser a
financial adviser that sells universal
index is an insurance agent they're not
a financial adviser yeah that's what I
kind of started to learn because my
parents also are invested to him and I
found out what he has him on is also
another life insurance product so I
think he just you know he doesn't yeah
he doesn't really do Investments he just
sells
Insurance yeah he makes a lot of money
on it too oh like he made as much as you
lost on this deal this year yeah that's
the other thing I talk about this Dave
in my new book Breaking Free from broke
I have a whole chapter on investing
traps and I took a lot of time on the
permanent life insurance section because
too many young people are falling for
this it's you know come back around it's
got you know the Tik Tok idiots have
stepped up and are really hammering this
stuff well they call themselves Dave
tax-free wealth strategists that's what
they they don't call themselves
financial advisors anymore cuz it's it's
cooler to call yourself a wealth
strategist here's the here's the dumb
butt part of that okay taxfree wealth
wealth strategist now let me tell you
how you get tax-free money out of a
permanent life insurance policy number
one you pay into it for years and years
and years years pass this thing he's got
no Val he's got no cash value right now
after a year of paying in 150 just what
we've been telling you for years they
keep it all once you get past that you
finally build up a little bit of
horrible Pocket Change piss poor returns
and you got $2,000 in there you keep
doing it for your whole stupid life and
that would be a stupid life um and you
got
50,000 bucks in there you know how you
get your 50,000 bucks out
taxfree borrow it you borrow it well
guess what if you go the bank and borrow
$10,000 it's tax-free borrowed money
never is taxed it's dumber and hell but
it's not taxed it sounds cooler when
taxfree in front of it that's
unbelievable yeah of course it's taxfree
you idiot not you not you Dalton but the
yeah Dalton but the the the the guy I'm
a taxfree well strategist well of course
you are the way you get your money out
you borrow your own stupid money out of
this policy and you pay them interest of
course it's tax free borrowed money has
never got taxes on it that's dumb don't
poke holes in their genius strategy Dave
it's a gen they bunch of gen I'm a I'm a
taxfree weal strat this is the I have a
hot take for every investment hot take
go down the bank and borrow 15,000 bucks
that's taxfree here's what I say I said
permanent life insurance as a wealth
building tool is a legal scam pedal by
insurance agents post as financial
advisers it gives them fat commissions
and locks you into a lifetime of stupid
tax Dalton is exhibit a and luckily he's
getting hey he's B he's B Dave did it
before it was cool now it's trendy on
Tik Tok it's why it still makes me mad
oh my goodness of course the guy the the
fraternity bro right makes it even worse
you know how long he was in the business
about 20 minutes after he sold our
policy he was gone cuz that's 80% of
those agents are out of the business in
one year so much turn 80% well they must
lose their soul in the first three
months selling this they don't lose
their soul until they sold all their
family and friends there we go and then
when they try to sell it to individuals
who are actually using their brain
instead of the relationship to make the
sale then they find out they lost their
soul oh that's what happens and they get
out of the business they run out of
steam but the business is set up to the
industry is set up to milk your your
sphere of influence so they put you in
there as a greeny they milk your sphere
of influence your natural market and
they tell you go after your friends and
Young col we're going to serve your
natural market oh my
gosh with a tax-free wealth
strategy shoot me brilliant just shoot
me create your free every dooll budget
today the simplest way to budget for
your life